(suspenseful music)
- I hope he can guess
it, but if he doesn't
I won't dump him.
- It might throw a wrench in
that whole one year thing.
- No.
- So we'll see.
(upbeat music)
Her hand's a little smaller
and so it feels a little different.
So we'll have to see.
I'm sorry to the person on the other side.
This is weird.
I'm like trying to test out her knuckles
I'm like, is that Saf's knuckles
or is that somebody else's?
But then again, I don't even
know what Safiya's knuckles
feel like, so I don't even
know why I'm trying that.
There's a little bit of
gamesmanship going on here.
I think that part of you
guys might have been like
let's put Safiya first, trick out Tyler.
Oh, this is tricky now.
Now this hand is a little bit bigger
and Safiya's got pretty big hands.
This is impossible.
(laughs)
I'm in pretty intense thought right now,
but this feels like a hand that I know.
It's like the warmth a little bit
and I'm adding in some descriptors
which can only hurt me if I'm wrong.
I'm like, this hand feels
like a hand I've been holding.
Okay, this is Safiya's hand.
I think Safiya's hand is number three
and I'm really hoping that it is
because I'm pretty nervous right now.
No, who is that?
It's two then.
Oh my god!
No, I thought I would have known.
I don't want to see, she's gonna be mad.
- Are you serious?
I would've been so good at this.
- No, stop.
It was not that easy,
I couldn't really tell.
- He did horribly.
Why did you think that the
first hand was not my hand?
- We don't walk this far
apart, is really what it is.
So, we usually walk
right next to each other
and so we're farther apart,
it just felt different.
Like the angle was different.
- No, it's fine.
I'm not mad, I'm just disappointed.
- Listen, I've held one hand for a year
and maybe if other people get them then
they're better at holding hands than us.
I think that we're pretty awesome
with being boyfriend
and girlfriend, right?
- Yeah.
- There you go.